[Music]
so covet times are crazy right and a lot
of people have gone back to school
and now we're getting to see how
interesting the
2020 school year is it is because right
now there's this
this tick tock that went viral of this
girl who got
some stuff sent to her from her
physiology
class and we're gonna we're gonna look
at it what was it a prosthetic dick
let's see here we go
unboxing so
this is really really precious
[Music]
oh my god is that a baby no this is a
cat
well it's a baby pig does that mean
afterwards they're gonna cook it in the
soup or something
i don't think that's edible i think it's
preserved yeah there's a ton of
preservatives in it so it's like pickles
from aldehyde pickles
crazy so it's virtual learning i would
never i can't
yeah so this is julie she's uh going to
school
in arizona arizona
yeah so recently she did that tick tock
about her
her class sending her this fetus this
baby
fetus i mean pig pig fetus and piglet
it has like all these instructions on
how to dissect it and stuff
and so the plan is they sent her all
these things
and she's supposed to be dissecting it
along with the class
like once a week i believe so she has to
hold on to mommy
once a week yeah she has to hold on to
all these animals
and stuff no so she asked like how are
we supposed to store these things and
they just said
to leave it in room temperature so now
it's just chilling in her hallway can
you imagine
the smell how bad it is when she opens
it because they said that they were
already smelling it
in the packaging and it's like vacuum
packaged probably yeah so imagine when
it opens up and it sounds like she has
roommates
oh so she has other roommates and
they're all in the same class and now
they have
three sets of the same [ __ ] at least
it's like it's like everyone's in the
same field
yeah they're not just like oh i'm a film
major but i gotta deal with all these
dead animal smells
where do you even like dissect it on the
dinner table or you take it to the
garage
so she says that she imagine like she
thinks that they're going to be
dissecting it outdoors
because the smell is so intense imagine
the neighbors
they're like what the [ __ ] is happening
good bodies over there kind of barbecue
can we just make 20 like
can we just everything that's happening
we just freeze it so like freeze your
bank account freeze your job freeze your
schooling freeze
everything for 2020 and just be like the
show let's pretend what freeze this show
no no not the show we need entertainment
but um
yeah for 2020 we just do it all over in
2021 like we just don't count it can we
do that
don't freeze my computer i need it for
porn
well we can watch everything that was
produced in up until 2019. okay but
everything else is frozen yeah there's a
lot of videos
that was packaged um prior to like if
they've already been doing that
like i wonder if maybe that's how they
send it to the school
possibly with the instructions and stuff
or maybe they just made quick seems like
they adapted yeah yeah seems like
it did real quick that company who sends
him out then pivoting like a
[ __ ]
smart it makes sense i like it honestly
so i just made that joke but
i actually like the ingenuity that and
just the creativeness and the
resourcefulness that i'm seeing just
across different industries because i'm
like tight like it just shows you
you're not meant to be in a box always
like it's all adaptable
yeah it's cool to just like pivot and
adjust and then and then things
are gonna change things people have to
have had to do it i'm sure like
medieval times and stuff and like
pre-united states they've all had to
pivot because
maybe because of some disease or some
like technological thing but yeah i was
talking going through it now
yeah i was talking to your mom and i'm
like you know i think for people in our
age we're always like um
is this the one if you were asking if
she gave blow jobs oh okay
no that's another another conversation
but uh you know in our age we're like
the age of internet right so it's like
like we see the world transform
pre-internet to
now there being internet and i'm like
man that's crazy like we're the only
generation that experienced that
and then when i was talking to your mom
it reminded me of what my mom was
telling me when she was growing up
before
like taiwan had complete infrastructure
put in
most of the people that she knew had
outhouses wow and your mom also had an
outhouse
so i'm like damn so like plumbing was
like the internet of their day
and then their difference is like do you
remember we used to [ __ ] outside and now
we could [ __ ] inside and that was
probably like revolutionary
i like [ __ ] outside and i'm like man
that's crazy yeah it wasn't even tv
it was a toilet yeah and it's just gonna
constantly keep changing no matter like
we have to just be adaptable when my
ancient ass grandma was alive
she remembers when cars were starting to
be used in japan
wow that's an ancient ass base
oh rode horses and stuff like that too
damn
my grandparents would do for sure did
you take it to the horse washing
recently casey and i were talking about
that whole concept of like you know
how how times are so different and how
things change so drastically so
we were staying in this cabin that this
cabin was built in the 60s 1966
and the same appliances the same
carpet that they used was still there
whoa
what the hell to the point where they
still have carpet in the bathrooms
and i was so just god yes did it smell
funny
i didn't want to smell there's 1966
poopoo there
oh my god it was so gross i'm like how
do you still have carpet in the toilet
like right
where the toilet is but anyway so then
we started thinking about that we're
like oh how gross carpet in the bathroom
like yuck
was it even a fridge or was it an ice
box no it was a fridge but it was like
top of the line like really it it looks
like
so brand new it's almost like time
traveling back to the 60s to see these
appliances
be like so like pristine but anyway we
were talking about that we're like
you know what's crazy how we have carpet
in our cars i bet you in the future
it's going to be like wood floors why
did they have carpet in their cars like
there's like [ __ ] dirt and
and all these like things in the carpet
it gets stuck it's so nasty it might get
tile
it's not a car i have seen hardwood
floor yeah
hardwoods in a van vans do that yeah
yeah
i wanna i like remember when the uh was
it the fj cruiser or the [ __ ]
oh i don't know it was one of those
sporty cars where you can just like
hose it down that's the gp no it was an
element
element that was the one that they
marketed it yeah they marketed
in the commercials and stuff yeah but
they they [ __ ] off the jeep though
yeah my jeep i didn't have carpet in it
since like the first year i owned it
because right when i got my dog he was
scared
of uh he was scared of cars i didn't
know that and uh
that big guy yeah yeah yeah he was
scared of everything he's scared of
pigeons right
like a hundred pound dog yeah he's big
scared of everything and uh so
my second car ride with him he uh he
started
like freaking out so he would like poop
in one direction and throw up on the
other
and then turn around and poop in the
other direction and throw him in the
other wow and
and he just started stepping in it and
it went into the cracks and everything
oh my god
and i remember i got home and i was just
like poor you who do i call
like what do i do right now yeah i was
just like [ __ ] what do i do i remember i
just
stared at it for like 10 minutes and i
take it back to the dealership
you guys gave it to me like this but
then i remember that you could hose it
out yeah so i just like pulled out the
carpet unplugged the bottom
holds out the whole thing so you don't
have carpet floors anymore
or the map i don't even have the car
anymore but throughout the whole car
dude he had to [ __ ] torch it i
promise
he was yeah but after that yeah i didn't
have a carpet anymore because i was like
this is kind of sick like any time it
just gets
messy it just holds the whole thing down
that's true and then after that
conversation with casey i ended up
ordering the
the mats for the car because i'm like oh
weather mats or like
rubber mats i mean that's why we take
off our shoes
yeah right like because we're bringing
all the outside world
into the house that's why you gotta take
off your shoes when you drive your car
i don't know where my right danger is
you should why
well because yeah because then your
carpet's dirty if you've been stepping
on it and then it just dirties up your
dope shoes i just take off my shoes
everywhere
like everything right now no they're not
he literally
ignore outdoor everywhere is it harder
for you to drive without shoes because
it's harder for me
i like to drive with out my shoes oh the
manual
if i have sandals on um i i take them
off
because i drive with my toe that's why
it feels weird it feels like i'm trying
to push with my toes
i think i'm spongebob walk around naked
and i mean not naked uh you have to have
enough you have to have it it's like
this
like spongebob the big toe if you walk
around
barefoot a lot you're uh you actually
regain like your
toes abilities and it's fine most people
they only know how to do this with their
toe i thought it was illegal or
something to drive without shoes
how they're gonna [ __ ] pull me over
huh i've always thought that
my parents would tell me that yeah her
parents saw us a bunch of crazy [ __ ]
like you can't turn on the lights in the
car
yeah that one's [ __ ] that one's so
funny yeah why would they say that
it's a [ __ ] stupid they don't want to
turn on the ac because it's to waste all
the gas
all the good it was like that is how it
was back then but it's more efficient
now
because the compressor runs off of the
engine you can't have too many keys on
your keychain because then like when you
put the key into the ignition it's going
to loosen it i feel like that
is true i've seen a lot of people with
it
yeah i mean it does make sense right it
makes sense and you just got a new car
yeah i did just get a new car i got a
tacoma trd
4x4 road floor you did the trt packet
trt package you're offroad yeah heck
yeah
congrats what made you go is it because
your dog [ __ ] all over your jeep
no that was years ago uh it's because
like since i have a house i'm always
doing [ __ ] to my house all the time
and then [ __ ] up your house the most
recent purchase that we wanted to buy
was a new backyard door
with a big doggy door and a big window
because right now it's just a solid door
yeah uh and i like i like doing things
myself
so i want to be able to install the door
myself pull it out but then
to ship it to my house it's like a
hundred bucks so i was like i gotta pick
it up from home depot
and my little two-door jeep i just can't
do that
and i i found myself screaming like
every day of like i need a truck
like i said this like every day for like
another truck you're just gonna save a
hundred bucks you ended up spending like
40 grand
things throughout the month you know
i need to save money in this
[ __ ] i like i legit rented a
truck recently
because i needed a package and it it
just wouldn't fit in my car
i had to rent like a u-haul f-150s to
drive it home
and i was like this shit's adding up at
this point that's when it sold you
like i need a truck yeah that's
dope how your brain works it's like i
need this [ __ ] i gotta spend it
well actually trading in my jeep jeeps
lose like no value
really my jeep covers entirely cool
like i bought my jeep for like 24k and i
traded in for like 19.
wow five years and you got to use two i
bought it new
yeah i bought a new off the lot amazing
that's really good
my first car was at tacoma as well it's
still around
like 200 000 plus miles or whatever oh
[ __ ] yeah my mom still uses it and like
i'll go home if i need to you drive a
truck
yeah i mean it's not an off-road it's
but why you got a truck though
is it to carry your drum set it really
was though
i got it the piano the piano was so big
that i would bring
i don't bring a big piano anymore around
because it's like a piano but let me
know like a keyboard [ __ ] pushing it up
and down
yeah because every time you move it you
gotta get it tuned right
so that's why i'm like why would you do
that right i meant keyboard
technically speaking and i was carrying
on this huge one that was like
80 pounds with the case and stuff and my
god damn
do you know how to tune pianos no that's
that's crazy
i know are you about to ask him for a
favor yeah
my uncle does though okay so you know
like little [ __ ]
i just moved my piano so i need to get
it right
and i mean it has to be like silent in
the whole house the whole time
yeah wow it's pretty crazy it's a pretty
cool job
you